quick introduction I know hardly anybody
says they care about helicopters but as
God is my witness I'm gonna change that
if I can reach one of you airplane
obsessed folks I will do my best okay so
what is cool about a helicopter here
it's a view so let's start first and
foremost it's a view so these are some
pictures that I snapped on a trip from
the Robinson factory in Los Angeles back
to Boston who recognizes the city in the
middle ooh
some Midwesterners here Chicago indeed
all right of course this is the Stata
Center where we will be tomorrow
remember that 30 to 141 all right one of
the parts of the helicopter if you're
between ages three and five it's
acceptable to call the thing on the top
the propeller but older than that it's
better to say main rotor system tail
rotor is in the back we'll talk about
why we need that in a minute you got to
have transmissions in helicopters the
speed of the engine is never the speed
that you want
I don't think and landing gear is kind
of nice although for record-setting
flights sometimes people have taken them
off to try to get a little higher a
little faster and they just land very
gently okay so your typical helicopter
drivetrain will have transmissions
in both for both the main rotor and
they'll have another transmission to
adjust the speed of the tail maybe your
back up a little bit this unfortunately
does introduce another source of
unreliability so in the airplane you
know you've got your engine it's bolted
to the propeller as long as the engines
turning you really it's hard to have a
problem that propellers don't generally
just come apart in flight but here with
the helicopter you might have a working
engine and working main rotor
and the transmission all the oil might
come out in the gear seized up so you've
got a there's a couple warning lights in
there for when you're having a
transmission problem this is the rubber
belt system that's used in some piston
helicopters I think this is probably a
drawing off of a Robinson but basically
you have pulleys on the engine side and
on the drivetrain side and you have
these rubber belts connecting them so
you can start your engine with the belts
loose and then tighten them up when you
want the engine to begin driving the
rotor system that way you don't have to
have the little starter motor actually
turn all the rotors and stuff all right
how does it work
so Tina is a hard act to follow
with my cave-person computer programmers
understanding of lift but if you assume
that lift is a combination of Newton's
third law and their Bernoulli principle
the the sped up air has more kinetic
energy therefore it has to have for
conservation of energy has to have less
of something else it's going to have
lower static pressure so here's one of
the F phase diagrams here right you have
velocity and pressure that are equal
they go into the venturi the velocity is
higher the pressure is lower so the
energy of the air is still the same and
it comes out again at the same velocity
and pressure so you're getting lift from
the wing from both Newton's third law
just pushing air down makes the wing go
up and there Bernoulli principle of
generating some low pressure this is the
same drawing you saw earlier of how when
you exceed a certain critical angle of
attack depending on the airfoil your
lift your lift party comes to a quick
end it doesn't go away completely but
it's a sudden drop angle of attack so
remember there's your chord line there's
your relative wind four degree angle of
attack and a reasonable amount of
forward speed remember the lift series
is the speed squared will have you going
and if you want to fly slowly you just
go to higher and higher angles
attack so why not hover in your system
172 and save yourself the trouble of
getting a helicopter rating it's because
you know off the right end of this chart
you quickly get to the stalling angle of
attack and the plane doesn't fly anymore
so there's an F a drawing I think from
the pilots handbook where the air flow
becomes turbulent somewhere between 12
and 16 degrees angle of attack depending
on the airfoil and that's why the Cessna
can't be used for hovering operations
all right what if you saw the wing off
the Cessna and spin it around so if you
do that the wing will always have
airspeed even if the fuselage is not
moving and that was an idea that was
first reduced to practice in 1907 so
only four years after the Wright
brothers flew a couple guys in France
were actually hovering a little bit in
the helicopter the first helicopters
that could be flown and controlled and
you know actually operated as you know a
practical aircraft I think you know mid
30s in Germany and then Sikorsky is
famous for being the first mass producer
of helicopters with the Sikorsky r4 it
was briefly it was used for a few
operational purposes in World War two
search-and-rescue type stuff but really
you know Korea the Korean War was the
first time that helicopters were widely
used by the military alright let's talk
about a very simple qualitative physics
here we're spinning on the ramp and
we're hovering we're sorry we're
spinning on the ramp so we spin the
rotor system up to 400 rpm but we're
still on the ramp so does anybody have a
brilliant idea for how do we get up into
the air where we want to be is there
okay excellent so what's your name sorry
Aziz has a correct observation that if
you want to get the same lift out of a
wing without changing the speed we don't
want to have this we don't want to speed
up too much because the tips will go
supersonic and the neighbors will begin
to complain so we just twist the blades
up a little bit and as they're twisted
up they'll bite more air generate more
lift and the helicopter will begin
rising up what will happen to the speed
let's hear from one of these Aero
engineering heroes as we generate more
lift what happens more lift more drag
so without adding more power the engine
well without adding more power the
blades will slow down so you want a
correlator as you're lifting the
collective control on a helicopter the
correlator is opening the throttle and
adding more power automatically and
there's also an electronic governor that
I'll just touch that up a little bit by
watching the RPM turbine helicopters all
have governor's most piston Robinsons
have governor's as well all right so
what if we are parked on ice has anybody
here seen my favorite movie blades of
glory
so when Will Ferrell and his partner
what if they're on the ice and they
pushed each other what happens both go
backwards right the pusher and the pushy
so keeping in mind blades of glory an
important physics work
what if we're parked on the ice what
happens to our helicopter after we start
the engine and start the blades spinning
helicopter students the other way
excellent yeah so that's Newton's third
law once again right for every action
there's an equal and opposite reaction
you're not going to see that as
dramatically if you're parked on
pavement because of the friction so what
do we do we Oh we add the tail rotor so
yeah here the forces up here there's the
blade rotation
there's the torque to counteract the
torque we've got the tail rotor thrust
to blow the tail back into position and
the only thing here that's not corrected
you'll notice is the tail rotor thrust
so if you set everything up the way you
would think obvious like put the rotor
mass straight up and put the tail rotor
on it the whole helicopter with the
controls neutral would drift to the
right from the tail rotor thrust so
right because it's pushing the tail the
helicopter wants to rotate the
helicopter wants to rotate that way the
tail rotor blows it back this way
and that would blow the whole machine
off the side of the ramp if the pilot
didn't hold a lot of left cyclic so to
counteract that the helicopters are
rigged with the mast at a slight left
angle so that they don't have this
tendency to go off to their right the
governor okay yeah so let me reinforce
that so yes as you generate lift you get
more drag which will cause the blades to
slow down so there's a mechanical
correlation as you're raising the
collective the throttles being opened
just kind of blindly and the governor is
touching that up the governor is
watching and maybe twisting the throttle
control slightly to fine tune the
throttle to keep the blades exactly at
400 rpm let's say that's the 100 for a
pilot pilots are you know you don't want
to distract the pilot too much so the
gauge is just calibrated in percent it's
a 100 percent rpm that's good that's all
you need to know about your helicopter
it you know I think in the Robinson it
works out to pretty close to 400 rpm
all right forward flight
so we're hovering and we want to go
forward so it seems obvious that we want
to tilt the fan right we want to push
the fan down this way and that way we'll
get some horizontal vector of thrust and
we'll be going forward but where do we
push it from right from according to
it's a spinning gyro so it has a lot of
stability if we're really strong and we
reach up from our pilot seat and try to
nudge the rotor system why wouldn't that
just cause the helicopter fuselage to
move underneath the fixed rotor system
instead of moving the rotor system
there's nothing to fix unless we can
call up you know an incredibly strong
friend and say hey who's you mind
holding the helicopter and fix position
we don't have anything to push against
in order to tilt the rotor does that
make sense
you got this gyro on top of you and
disturbing and it's gonna take a lot of
power and even if you had the strength
you don't have anywhere to stand rigidly
and push so what do you think could the
rotor just fly itself into a new
position and how would that work like
how could you use the spinning wing
itself to fly itself into a new tilted
down position anybody have any brilliant
ideas john has a good idea so John says
increase the angle of attack and
decrease it as the blade moves around
the disc so if you can increase the lift
on part of the disc compared to another
part of the disc it will naturally tilt
itself so if you want to go forward
let's ignore gyroscopic precession for a
moment because I think we've proven that
nobody understands it let's just say
that we could make the angle of attack
higher on the back of the disc compared
to the front then the back of the disc
would have more lift it would rise it
rise up and the front would go lower and
then you would see this flight path that
you do see that makes sense so basically
you're controlling you're basically
flying the rotor system you're not
flying the helicopter the helicopters is
hanging from the rotor system that's a
good mental model and all the power is
you know from the engine to the rotor
system so that's a natural place to do
it just by tweaking the blade angle as
it rotates around so left hand is
collective moving the blades angle
regardless of where they are on the disc
and the cyclic which is changing the
pitch cyclically as is suggested all
right Andy what's the magic this design
I'm not sure it's really changed at all
since the very first helicopters maybe
those brothers in Paris didn't have one
in 1907 but I'm pretty sure that every
helicopter since then has had this
there's a swash plate oh watch this so
the lower part of the swash plate here
is fixed and connected to the flight
controls and then there's a bearing and
the upper swash plate rotates with the
Blaz
does that make sense so if you lift a
lower swash plate up that pushes the
upper swash plate up which pushes these
rods that are connected to a corner of
the blade and that'll cause the blades
to tilt that makes sense so you have
this rotating swash plate that's
connected to a corner of the blade and
if you push the whole thing up by
yanking up on the collective then you
can see the blades actually twist you
can do that in the hangar and see the
effect of this at the same time in your
right hand is the cyclic and with the
cyclic you're tilting the swash plate so
with the tilted swash plate that will
just cause the blades to tilt up sorry
the it'll cause the blades to twist up
and twist down as they rotate so it's a
pretty elegant solution this is not
carrying much of the load of the
helicopter you know there's still a mast
holding the whole thing up this is
really just
has to carry enough force to twist the
blades up and down up and down up and
down
so that's your engineering design
everybody appreciates that okay do we
want to take off straight up like in a
Hollywood movie well if you have one or
two people in a helicopter design for
four or five that you actually do have
enough power to do that however there's
something over here on the right called
the height velocity diagram and you can
see it says avoid operation in shaded
areas so they're saying we'll talk about
this maybe a little later if people are
interested but if you are let's say up
at 200 feet at zero airspeed so you're
just parked hovering 200 feet above the
ground you don't have huge stores of
forward speed which is a kinetic energy
or potential energy because you're only
up 200 feet so it's gonna be hard to do
an auto rotation that's perfect and
doesn't bend anything especially because
the FAA says if you're up high like that
and the engine quits in test piloting
you have to sit there with your arms
folded for one second and do nothing
because that's what would probably
happen in real life you know you'd be
surprised people can do Auto rotations
from 200 feet and land perfectly but
they know it's coming they chop the
throttle themselves they immediately put
the collective down and they do the auto
rotation so but basically if you're a
pilot of average skill and you don't do
anything for about a second after the
engine quits then this is supposed to
keep you safe by you either fly 50 knots
or faster or you fly you know 400 feet
or higher at sea level and higher than
that at high altitude alright so what
we're actually recommended to do see
this recommended takeoff profile is skim
along the ground until we get up to
about 45 knots and then what the hell
top to climb I think this is the curve
for a Robinson r44 why would you want to
do that aside from safety well another
good reason to do that is you watch
these drag versus speed curves and you
see that you reach kind of a minimum
this is this is some generic helicopter
from an F a book it's actually 55 knots
for the Robinson but if you can go 55
knots you need less energy than any
other airspeed so the idea for takeoff
is you nudge the helicopter forward a
little bit if you can build up two knots
of speed that gives you excess power you
can use that excess power to climb up
three inches or you can use that excess
power to accelerate maybe to three or
four knots and if you just keep
accelerating using your extra power to
accelerate the faster you go the less
power you need so even if you've never
touched a collective or drawn any more
horsepower as long as you have an open
area in front of you you'll accelerate
and once you hit 45 or 55 knots you now
have your hover power turns into
significant excess power that you can
use for a climb so that's why you often
see helicopters at airports taking off
kind of like a short field airplane and
also landing a bit like a short filler
airplane all right
straight and level it's very similar to
an airplane the performance is all is a
function of the attitude that the
aircraft is in is it pitched up or down
and how much power is being applied and
that's an indirect function of the
collective position so as with an
airplane remember your pitch controls
your speed and the amount of power
throttle and the airplane collective and
the helicopter determines whether you're
climbing or descending at that airspeed
your attitude indicator in a VFR
helicopter is the horizon so you're
watching horizon carefully the reason
why people people who are instrument
rated airplane pilots they jump into the
helicopter and they can fly it
immediately and people who've never
flown have a tough time it takes them
you know 10 hours and the reason is that
people who are instrument rated airplane
pilots they become very sensitive to
watching for small changes
in attitude alright the anti-torque
pedals remember we had that tail rotor
and we adjust it so that the tail
doesn't spin around on the ground in the
air we adjusted so that the helicopters
streamlined into the wind we don't
actually have to use them to make turns
there's no adverse yaw as in some
airplanes where I'll start skidding or
there's none of that
so basically or slipping all we do is to
make a turn is we put the helicopter
using the cyclic into a little bit of a
bank and then we wait so if we have you
know let's say a 10 degree Bank the
helicopter in one minute will make a 180
degree turn landing with power so again
like an airplane if you see the spot in
the ground
you adjust the power so you don't over
fly the spot or under fly the spot if
the spots rising up in the windshield
from your perspective that means you're
gonna land short so you add power raised
collective in the helicopter if the spot
is descending then you're over flying
the spot so you have to reduce power
it's a purely physical it's a purely
visual maneuver except when you're
landing on a pinnacle and the reason for
that is if you're landing on a pinnacle
you don't get a sensation of your
forward speed from the ground rushing by
so the ideal the idea and the helicopter
is to land unlike with the airplane it's
actually a little bit it's a little bit
less unnerving than an airplane some
people get a little bit ground shy in
the airplane like they're happy flying
80 knots in the pattern but they're not
that happy flying 70 knots you know 10
feet above the runway which makes sense
because you don't want to slam into the
ground going really fast well the good
news is in the helicopter you never get
to that phase where you're going fast
close to the ground because when you're
landing you just say you know how in my
peripheral vision how fast is the ground
rushing by and
just kind of keep that constant whatever
it was up at 500 feet above the ground
that's what you want when you're 5 feet
above the ground and you'll very
naturally slow down you'll do the right
your natural instinct to slow down as
the ground begins rushing is a helpful
one in the helicopter so your peripheral
vision is used for speed reference and
the spot moving up or down is used for a
descent rate reference and that's you
never have to look inside at the gauges
except when you're landing on top of an
office building or something all right
can you land the helicopter without
power it turns out the answer is yes you
have these three buckets of energy that
I alluded to earlier kinetic from your
forward airspeed potential from being up
high and then another form of kinetic
which we'll call blade inertia from
their relatively heavy blades spinning
so raise your hand if you think the
forward air speed is number one in terms
of size let's rank these what's what's
the biggest air speed going a heavy
helicopter going 100 knots potential
energy the helicopter having been lifted
up off the ground or the blades whipping
around near the speed of sound okay who
votes for one forward airspeed a few who
votes for potential a fair number who
votes for blade inertia the blades
whipping around all right good we got a
good distribution okay well let me give
you I'll tell you about I think it was a
crazy French guy who got into your
what's now called a gyro copter and
Alouette and went up to 40,000 feet to
set an altitude record the record was
set when the engines flamed out that's
why it's you know 40,000 and change not
41,000 and change and then Auto rotated
all the way down to the ground so
whatever energy bucket that was there
had to be sufficient to make it all the
way the ground so what does that tell
you the biggest one is it's got to be
something that scales up to 40,000 feet
potential yeah so potential energy is a
good candidate for the biggest because
again if you you know you got to keep
the rotor spinning for longer if you're
Auto rotating from ten thousand feet or
fifty thousand feet or whoever I don't
think that records been broken actually
it was set in the 70s okay so number two
is the forward air speed of the
helicopter the blade inertia isn't good
for much except for cushioning your fall
from five or ten feet above the ground
so what you do in the helicopter would
if the engine were to fail number one
reason is fuel starvation from failing
to top it off
helicopters are often short on payload
so people will say well I want to take
these seven people somewhere and I'd be
overweight if I fell to the fuel tank so
I'll put an you know half an hour of
fuel for this 15 minute trip actually
that would be illegal twenty minutes is
the minimum reserve so I'll put in half
an hour if you offered this ten minute
trip and then you know there's a bit of
a delay and you run out of fuel there's
a warning might at ten minutes all right
and the good news is you can land in the
field you know baseball field pretty
easily alright so the engine quits for
whatever reason let's say you've run out
of fuel you want to get to 60 or 70
knots some reasonable air speed and then
the challenge is to hold that air speed
even as the ground is rushing up at you
you hold it right till you're at
treetops height about forty feet above
the ground then you begin to flare just
like in an airplane flaring for landing
you scrub off that forward speed and
that reduces your descent rate so you
can reduce your descent rate to zero by
bleeding off all that energy from the
forward air speed and the kinetic energy
remember is MV squared so it's very
important there's twice as much energy
at 70 knots compared to 50 knots
so once you've scrubbed off all your
descent rate and all your forward speed
you're like this so your tails will be
low and now you're gonna just follow the
ground and hit the tail first so it's
not going to be an FAA quality you're
gonna walk away but it's not going to be
an FAA quality landing so what you can
do is stick forward and settle by
pulling up on the collective so you
stick forward to level the skids
and then when you're about five feet
above the ground or maybe two feet above
the ground you start pulling up on the
collective to cushion your fall that
last few feet so you've used up
potential energy keeping the blades
windmilling
if you just flatten the collective the
blades will have a relatively normal
angle of attack to the air that's now
coming from below you've kept up your
forward speed and you bleed that off at
the end to reduce your vertical speed
and then finally you go
I think I cheated
what's the cheat and I'm gonna I'm
telling you the cheat is you can hear it
you could hear the cheating going on he
landed with zero forward air speed why
what enabled that and like I said you
could hear it it's not from the engine
running the engine was presumably at
idle okay so what was the cheat nobody
hurt wind exactly yes what's your name
messin figured this out so basically he
landed with probably it's very hard to
kill all of your vertical speed and all
of your forward speed so if you go out
and it's 15 knots down the runway if you
can just get down to 15 knots and
instead of sliding and gone down the
runway which is common and not not
harmful to the helicopter you'll have a
perfect how it looks like a perfect
landing it's very hard and the big
helicopters like a Huey or something
it's practical to do a zero-zero landing
out of an auto all the time and in
Robinson it can be tough but the wind
helps hugely and the like I said the
throttle was down at idle so the engines
not really doing anything question
it is yes great great question so
there's a sprag clutch which prevents
the rotor system from trying to drive
the engine because that would introduce
a lot more drag but the main rotor and
the tail rotor are yoked together so you
still have tail rotor control great
question yeah you need much I don't know
I have to think about why it's useful
yeah it's not useful for much that's for
sure
one thing is good about it is the
hydraulic pump is also geared into the
transmission so you still have hydraulic
boost even if you're off auto rotating
from super high what can you do with a
helicopter if you have a private you can
visit schools I visited the Winchester
public schools I'm not sure you can give
them all rides if you only have a
private there's some kind of like I said
those those charity laws that
regulations that we don't really worry
about because you know we have
commercial certificate and the letter of
authority from the Fisto but here's the
how here's one of the East Coast Aero
Club helicopters I flew to the public
schools and winchester's I gave all the
kids rides and when we flew over houses
like this I said oh that's just like the
house where I grew up if you do that
with kids from Weston and Lincoln they
believe you
they don't parse that as an ironic
statement all right helicopter pilot
careers just in case any of you guys are
thinking about leaving the desk world
people work as a flight instructor fly
tours in the Grand Canyon or Alaska and
then they'll either go to offshore oil
or medevac after that usually offshore
oil used to be easier to get when oil
when the oil prices are low when oil
catches a cold the helicopter industry
catches the flu they shut down these oil
rigs and there's a lot less need for
helicopter transport medevac has kind of
considered the plum job that's my friend
Marcus he trained at East Coast there
I'll come and now
he's hangs he does 12-hour shifts at a
volunteer fire station and he did he
gets paid in North Carolina and goes
hospital hospital or sometimes picks
people up off of highways and stuff so
what can you do
you can fly low and slow both legally
and safely he saw there was a carve out
for helicopters able to fly lower one
problematic aspect of flying Piper
warriors and Cessnas is that people
their expectations of what an aircraft
is and what it can do has been set by
their airline experience and the first
time we try to get up and use the
bathroom in your Piper
you'll discover that JetBlue has some
advantages in the aircraft department
and your passengers will notice this too
is this noisy it's not
climate-controlled there's no bathroom
the helicopters are awesome because
people usually haven't even been in one
so it's a whole different experience
it's a different view you can take them
on a 10-minute ride from Hanscom field
and go back you don't have to say oh
it's gonna have lunch in Martha's
Vineyard you just take them on a little
tour and they say wow this is awesome so
when I actually want to show people what
GA is like and what my world is like I
usually take them for a helicopter ride
I don't take them for a trip you know
the serious is for transportation and
the helicopter is really what I think of
as the kind of aviation dream that
people had you know in ancient Greece
like they didn't dream of going to LA
and for six hours they dreamt of you
know soaring like a bird you can land
off Airport that's where a lot of a
challenge comes from the helicopter you
know people think you're a pilot of
heroic skill if you take off and land at
Hanscom that's not very challenging it's
not really that different and in some
ways it's easier than landing taking off
and landing in a piper or a Cessna when
you're off Airport you have to exercise
a lot of judgment a lot of skill and
that's part of your training but it's
also where people get in trouble you
know hitting obstacles and stuff if you
do get all of your airplane skills you
can transfer them over to helicopters
very easily
it's thirty hours minimum of additional
training to add a helicopter rating 40s
probably a good budget number all right
are there are there helicopter questions
that is a great question you know is
there any regulation about where you can
land your helicopter the answer is you
know until about five or ten years ago
there wasn't any so it was just
permission of the property owner and you
know don't do anything careless or
reckless so basically the whole world
was open to helicopter pilots there is a
little bit of a tweaking of the law
the FAA passed this they add the out of
this regulation that I think was
intended for airplanes but they forgot
to carve it out so they said if you make
more than ten takeoffs and landings in
the same place in a year and you have to
get it approved as an airport with a
huge amount of regulation I think goes
intended for you know like mining
companies that would set up their own
landing strip it doesn't really make
sense for helicopters like if you have a
construction site that you want to
regularly visit now it's a bit of a
hassle because that eleventh landing in
theory you needed to get approval as an
airport but as a first approximation you
can land anywhere that the property
owner is happy to host you oh and towns
also like they haven't they they're
really aggressive about harassing people
who try to you know have a helipad at
their house now just cuz they can they
they get them under zoning laws even
though they're not really supposed to
the FAA you're supposed to have
exclusive authority to regulate aviation
because think about it there's all this
you know there's so many levels of
government in the u.s. if you let them
all just forbid activities they would
you know eventually there would be
nothing that was legal at all because
people in you know Concord and Lexington
would say well we don't want your planes
flying over our head so we'll just make
it illegal to fly a Gulfstream in
Concord
you know I I had that in the earlier
slide on learning to fly the marginal
cost is about double you know so it goes
from 150 an hour to 225 or 100 an hour
to 200 because so many rotating
components get discarded after 2200
hours so the transmissions the blades
and so forth so it is more expensive per
hour however like I also said the
flights tend to be a lot shorter so I
would say as a hobby overall it's about
the same cost because you're not
dragging people all the way to the
vineyard or Bar Harbor you're just
taking them into Boston and back out
which is about you know 20 minutes of 20
minutes of flight time in 30 minutes of
engine running time whereas you know an
intro airplane flight it would be an
all-day thing you'd probably fly a
couple hours two or three hours so you
actually probably spend more with the
airplane that's a great question
all right so I guess we should take a
10-minute restroom break and after that
we're gonna hear from lads about the
f-22
you